- ♪ I'ma [bleep] up on their
dick ♪
♪ [bleep] around and work, work,
work for that dick ♪
- ♪ Oh, I'd take a boat to that
dick ♪
- ♪ I'd [bleep] ride-a ride-a
goat to that dick ♪
- ♪ Fight Hurricane Maria for
the dick ♪
♪ Ride a missile from Korea for
the dick, hey ♪
- ♪ Ya'll want no problem with
that dick, girl ♪
♪ You know this pussy bomb like
Osama for that dick ♪
♪ I might just [bleep] on that
dick ♪
- ♪ Support Trump
for that dick ♪
♪ Sleep on the street, be a damn
bum for that dick ♪
- ♪ I'ma get crazy for that
dick ♪
♪ Damn right have a baby for
that dick ♪
- ♪ I go to trial
for that dick ♪
♪ I ain't no snitching [bleep] ♪
♪ It was him for that dick ♪
- ♪ Rob my grandma's purse for
that dick ♪
♪ And put me in a hearse for
that dick, hey ♪
- ♪ I'd say a prayer for the
dick ♪
♪ I'm always here for the dick ♪
♪ I do it all, so you know I
really care for the dick ♪
- ♪ Cut the head off Grand Puba
for the dick ♪
♪ [bleep] the D-R ♪
♪ Uber for the dick ♪
- ♪ Cancel HBO for the dick ♪
- Don't you got a show?
- ♪ Bitch, not no more for the
dick, hey ♪
- ♪ 'Bout to move to Cleveland
for that dick ♪
[laughter]
- Gaby!
Call me old-fashioned,
but they come across
kind of desperate.
Oh, internet.
Everyone's
doing their version of
Game Ova Reedy's "For
That D" freestyle.
And if you think the
ladies are horny,
you should hear the fellas.
- ♪ Finchy here to play for that
pussy ♪
- ♪ It's a play ♪
- ♪ I'd eat a [bleep] steak
in that pussy ♪
- ♪ I love steak ♪
- ♪ I'm facing strife for the
pussy ♪
♪ You can catch me at the altar
make her wife for the pussy ♪
- ♪ I'll beat my mama up for
that pussy ♪
- Not your mama.
- ♪ I done stole my mama's
drugs for that pussy ♪
- Man.
- ♪ I'd cook some eggs and bacon
for that pussy ♪
♪ Check my dreads like Jamaica
for the pussy ♪
- ♪ I'd rob a Chase for the
pussy, commit a homicide ♪
♪ I'ma lose some weight for that
pussy, yeah ♪
- ♪ Be a maid for the pussy ♪
♪ I'ma bake a cake for the
pussy ♪
- ♪ I'd fight for that pussy ♪
♪ Black Lives Matter, stand up
for my rights for that pussy ♪
- ♪ I love all the pussy ♪
♪ Protect and serve every day
for the pussy ♪
- They're all talk.
Most guys just text "u up?" for
that pussy.
Listen, I don't want to
dwell on the differences
between our private parts.
The country's divided
enough.
Meanwhile, buttholes
are over here
like, "What do I have to do?"
♪ I'd give up a Klondike for
that anus ♪
♪ Don't even care if you're
white for that anus ♪
♪ I'd leave my spouse for that
anus ♪
♪ I'd even take a loss on my
house for that anus ♪
♪ Spread your cheeks for that
anus ♪
♪ I'd claim responsibility for
White House leaks ♪
♪ For that anus ♪
♪ I'd get brain freeze for that
anus ♪
♪ I'd take a knee
for that anus ♪
♪ Get a lobotomy for that anus ♪
♪ I'd even join Scientology for
that anus ♪
♪ I'd rock cargo shorts for that
anus ♪
♪ I'd live in a pillow fort for
that anus ♪
♪ I'd watch "Young Sheldon" for
that anus, go to tech school ♪
♪ Learn a trade like welding for
that anus ♪
♪ I'd trade the first overall
pick for that anus ♪
♪ I'd [bleep] a dick for that
anus ♪
[microphone feedback]
Well, maybe I should have been
more specific.
I was talking about lady anus.